weird people canadians anyway let's move
on canadians canadians
speaking of canadians i i listen to the
harland episode of this podcast he's
canadian yeah like he is yeah i've
visited like 10 times it's one of my
favorite podcast episodes ever which one
the last last one we just did no 2018.
because he just back on you oh he just
did it yeah it's coming out soon oh dude
even better favorite you've been better
even better he's the best he's have you
had you have you been on his no but we
had him on ours oh did he do yours yeah
how do you do he was amazing
i mean let's talk about him for a second
yeah he's no paul walker
no i
honestly i think harlan is an angel on
earth like an actual literal like
han like i think he's a prophet what the
[ __ ] you say to me
he's like a ram das i think he's a
prophet yeah i think he's a walking
prophet
there's something about him that
transcends it all yeah he carries
everything very lightly yeah like he
doesn't bring any
like weight into the situation
everything's light with him yeah there's
like
loving awareness of everything good and
bad there's also a wiseness
about him he's wise you can go to him
with any kind of problem that you're
having and he gives you a very like
concise
advice mm-hmm
you don't understand what i'm saying
yeah he sees things cleanly cleanly very
clean right
um i bet he [ __ ] clean
yeah
i mean
do you think like he doesn't like
not a lot of like open mouth kissing
that's not what i meant but what did you
eat what do you mean then
like it's like very precise like you
know what i mean right like every
movement has an intention but that's
that's exactly what i that's what i'm
saying american psycho
christian cristiano ronaldo that's what
i thought you i thought you meant
sterile but you don't mean sterile you
mean like i mean cristiano ronaldo i
think personally not christian pursued
that christian pale no christian
christian when he's playing obviously
he's not like when he's you know who
that is yeah the soccer player right
when he's up there like everything looks
technical okay so you're not banging
he's not banging teeth with his partner
there's no awkward transition no it's
like
it's like she's going
are you professional
right you know what i mean like he's
like you're like you know oh you have a
certificate that's what you said what
about me yeah when i found her i'm like
you're a professional
like you have like you know a degree
you went to class like i
am like street smarts basquiat
just on the street just you know on the
wall but there's a lot of emotional
urgency to bask out i was at the day so
i get it yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of
emergency you can feel everything he's
feeling and everything he does why is
there does he have an um immersive
experience now no there's just a bunch
of his paintings at the broad and i was
there today so it's just
broden the broad museum in downtown
i want to go you should go it's fun yeah
they got a bunch of biz yeah because i
went to um tampa and i saw the dali one
he has a dolly expedition
exhibition yeah i heard a bunch of weird
[ __ ] about dolly lately uh recently like
what he's a fascist right yeah beyond
that but he's obvious
yeah but he was a sadist
like he would hurt animals really oh
that's not he would do a lot of like
really weird like intentional hurting of
beings around him and he got a kick out
of it that makes sense when you think
about his paintings yeah he's like i
melt you
you know yeah
yeah
you light a cat yeah like this would be
a good painting yeah i melted you don't
watch it you don't look at a deli plane
go oh this guy seems healthy
like this guy's like you got it together
no there's something going on right yeah
yeah the humans are like you know i mean
one eyeball a stick and then the rest of
it's melting like a candle right yeah i
mean and that's not you know i mean but
let me say something what you're saying
right now is blasphemy and hearsay
because we don't know the truth that bro
is dead
right the dalai dead the weird way to
say someone is perished
yeah well i'm with the [ __ ] god